okay good morning um so we are doing
Muhammad and the r of Islam
Today Muhammad um as you know is one of
the most
important and influential figures in
human history he is as important as
Jesus um but ironically we actually
don't know that much about
Muhammad in fact fact we probably know
more about Jesus than we know about
Muhammad with Jesus at least we have a
lot of his quotations a lot of his
sayings which give us insight
into his philosophy his religion his
thinking but but with Muhammad we don't
have that many quotations we don't have
that many written sources in fact the
Quran which is the holy book of the
Islamic ition doesn't really mention him
even though in theory it is written by
him in fact one of the um earliest
written documents about Muhammad is
actually from a Christian Bishop written
about 20 30 years after Muhammad's death
in 632 CE okay so we know he exist so we
know that he was a real person and he
was the founder of the Islamic tradition
and this is what um sibiel says about
Muhammad at that time a certain man from
along those same sons of Ishmael whose
name was mammed okay so mammed is
Muhammad in fact we we don't even know
what his real name is Muhammad just
means blessed one in Arabic a merchant
okay so he was a merchant as if by God's
command appeared to them as a preacher
so he was a prophet who rallied the the
U Arabs to his cause abing the their
vain Cults they turned to the Living God
who had appeared to the Father Abraham
okay so Muhammad converted the
polytheistic Arabs to the monism of the
Jews so mammed legislated for them not
to e carry on not to drink wine not to
speak falsely and not to engage in forn
fornication he said with an oath God
promised this land to Abraham and his
seed after him forever and he brought
about as he promised during that time
while he loved
ishmail okay so what he's saying is the
Arabs are the descendants of Abraham
just like the Jews and the
Christians but now you are the sons of
Abraham and God is accomplishing his
promise to Abraham and his seed to you
okay you have been you have God promised
you the promised land and now this land
has been taken away from you okay
Jerusalem um Israel has been taken away
from you and now we will take it back by
going to war Jihad holy
war love sincerely only the god of
Abraham and go and cease the land which
God gave to your father Abraham no no
one will be able to resist you in battle
because God is with you okay so this is
actually very similar the story of Moses
in the Bible right the the Jews were
enslaved in Egypt and Moses appeared
before them and promised to take them
back to
Israel right so this is
clearly following an ancient tradition
and so moabit in many ways is like Moses
in fact what's really strange is that in
the Quran the most um quoted figure the
figure that is most mentioned is Moses
not Muhammad or um Jesus okay so let's
try to figure out what's going on here
first of
all um what Muhammad is saying is that
Christians Jews and Arabs are all one
big family why
because in the Bible it says that
Abraham made a covenant with
Yahweh
Yahweh Abraham swore allegiance to
Yahweh in return Yahweh gave him the
promised land now the promised land is
not Israel the promised land is all that
territory going from the Nile to the
Tigers in modern day Iraq so basically
the entire Middle East okay that's what
the promised land is now this is
important because Abraham um had a wife
Sarah Sarah for most of her of her life
was not able to give
birth and if you don't
have um descendants if you don't have
children they don't get the promised
land right so in desperation Sarah gave
Abraham her maid named Hagar
and Abraham impregnant Hagar and Hagar
gave birth to a son named
ishmail and then
ishmail went to the Arabian Desert and
he is the father of the Arab
people okay and that's where Muhammad
comes from the
Arabs Sarah by the miracle of God would
eventually be able to give birth to the
the
Israelites okay and as we know the
Israelites will eventually become the
Christians so in other
words the Christians the Jews and the
Muslims they have a common ancestor in
Abraham okay so this is what so this is
what this is
saying so even though we don't have that
many written sources about Muhammad we
have something called the Hadi okay the
Hadi the Hadith is Arabic and it just
means an oral tradition so there are
these stories about Muhammad that has
been passed on orally from generation to
generation celebrating his life and so
let's go over what is traditionally
understood about Muhammad so Muhammad
was born in the year
570 into um an Arab tribe okay and he's
born born in a place called Mecca in the
Arabian
Desert he became a Traer because a
merchant because most people at that
time were either Nomads or
merchants and at a very young age he
married a very waly Widow and until the
age of 40 his life was prosperous but un
uninvent then
40 he started to
meditate in a cave okay that's a very
common thing to go to a cave um and to
meditate as a form of religious worship
and while he was at the Cave the angel
Gabriel appeared before Muhammad and he
said to
Muhammad you and your family
have lost away you are the descendants
of ishmail who brought the religion of
Yahweh to the desert back then you were
monotheistic but then over time you be
you became corrupted and became
polytheistic and so you have a mission
to
tell your fellow Arabs the story of
Yahweh the story of the
Bible and to return them to the love of
Yahweh return them to
monotheism and so Gabriel in a series of
Visions would
tell
Muhammad the story of the Bible okay
including Moses um his taking the people
uh the chan people the Jews from Egypt
back to the promised
land and this is considered a miracal
and true
because Muhammad was an illiterate
Merchant who had no exposure to the
Bible so this had to be true and this
shows that um this is all a miracle so
Muhammad is now inspired by the
Archangel Gabriel to to preach the word
of God but at this
time Arabia is a polytheistic primitive
and backward Society so the people of
Mecca reject him he spend 30 13 years in
Mecca preaching the word but they reject
him So eventually he decides to move to
Medina okay and this move is very
important it's called the hij
okay the immigration he and his
followers moved from Mecca to Medina and
this starts the Islamic tradition and
this marks the year zero in the Islamic
calendar just as the birth of Jesus
marks the year zero in the Christian
calendar okay so he goes to Medina
because the tribes there have invited
him to be a judge the tribes there uh
one of the tribes is actually Jewish
they're fighting amongst
themselves and they need someone to
arbitrate to arbitrate their disputes
and so Muhammad goes and he creates
something called the constitution of
Medina which promises is the freedom of
religious um expression to all people
okay there will be no religious
Prejudice in
Medina eventually over time more and
more followers are attracted to his
message of
monotheism and he starts to build a
following an
army and but because he's preaching a
faith that is counter the mainstream
Faith he gets attacked by other Arab
tribes and there are some setbacks but
through the love of God through the will
of God he triumphs over them and he
unites the Arabian
Peninsula now at this point they are a
threat to the two major world Empires at
this time the bantine Empire who the
hears to the Roman Empire as well as the
sassanian Persian
Empire and they both attack
him sorry they both attack the Muslims
but again through the miracle of God the
Muslims are able to defeat both
Empires and in less than 100 years they
conquer most of the
world
okay it is one of the greatest mysteries
in Ro history how this happened all
right how was it possible for Desert
people okay these are desert Nomads who
are poor PRI and backward how they were
able to
defeat two World Empires and Conquer
most of the world their empire at their
height would stretch from
Spain in the west all the way to India
and would
include Egypt the lavant
Mesopotamia and um
Iran okay very impressive how do they do
that and this mystery has never been
solved we will try in today's class to
solve this mystery in today's class
we'll try to answer three major
questions first of all who was Muhammad
really who was this person what did he
believe what did he want that's that's
first question second question
is how was this new religion
Islam able to try
all right and the third and last
question
is why do we know so little about the
early history of the Islamic
tradition okay so given that we know so
little about the early history and given
that there are few written sources about
the early history
and very little archaeology has been
done because Mecca and Medina are the
two holiest sites in the Islamic
tradition all right so we don't have
that much evidence in this situation we
can only use
historical
analogues are there historical incidents
that narrow or similar to what happened
uh in the Aran P Peninsula 1500 years
ago and the answer is there are some
there are actually many many
similarities all right so I was look at
three ones three I I'll just look at
three okay the first is from 1850 to
1864 in China there's something called
the typing
Rebellion I'm not sure if you know the
story but what happened was there was
this um young man only his 20s but his
name is honi Trent
and he's trying to become a scholar
official by taking the N by taking the
um
examination and he spelled three times
already after his third
attempt uh he runs into a Christian Miss
missionary who gives him a pamplet and
he just produces that pamphlet and he
learns about
Jesus then he has a dream where he meets
Jesus and Jesus tells him you're my
brother you're my little
brother and after
he fails the exam for the fourth time he
decides to
abandon um the that scholar official uh
route and embrace his Destiny as the
brother as a Chinese brother of
Jesus and eventually over the course of
10 years he's able to build a following
that
eventually conquers most of
China and is's almost able to
overthrow the Ching
Empire but there are some other factors
at work for example the Western Powers
mainly the British Empire intervene on
behalf of the of the Ching Dynasty so a
very similar
situation with the Muslim conquest of
the world right these are peasants who
have this very strange new
religion and somehow they're able to
beat a major
Empire and what the story of the typing
Rebellion tells us
is a new religion that is
revolutionary in the right social
historical economic
circumstances can be very
powerful okay so what drove the taiping
soldiers in battle was both the idea of
religious devotion God is with us and
revolutionary
Zeal we are making a new
world and when soldiers are infused with
both religious devotion and
revolutionary Zeal they're not afraid to
die they will fight to the death and
that's why they were able to overwhelm
the government's soldiers okay same
thing happened in something in something
called the war of the canudos from 1896
to 1898 in Europe the canudos is a
northern province in
Brazil and
Brazil um for its for it for most of its
history was an extremely racist Society
where minorities were persecuted by the
predominantly Spanish and white
colonizers and it was extremely unequal
Society where few landlords controlled
all the wealth so the
canoodles was a rebellion to overthrow
these landlords and establish a kingdom
of heaven it was led by this preacher
who preached the coming of the Kingdom
of Heaven just like
Jesus and he was surrounded by these
peasants who overthrew the landlords
they were surrounded by Bandits who were
criminals basically they didn't have any
guns they didn't have any weapons they
didn't have any soldiers the bris Army
saw them as a threat and they saw they
sent three Expeditions against these
peasants all three times the prison
prison Army was destroyed okay they lost
the battle why because again when
peasants have
revolutionary Zeal and religious
devotion they're not afraid to die and
so hand to
hand they were able to defeat the bridan
soldiers who were well armed and well
trained so so with the fourth Expedition
the brisen Army decided to send everyone
the entire brison Army was sent against
this peasant Uprising because they saw
this as a threat to the social order and
what they did was rather than engag the
peasants in handen combat directly they
surrounded the area with artillery and
they bombarded the uh peasants until
they were dead they basically nuked The
Peasants okay because they could not
defeat the peasants hand to hand or
directly and in both times the typing
rebellion and the war of of the canos
you can say it was a religious movement
but they were both revolutions they're
they were trying to overthrow the
established social
order okay so let's look at one more
example of this which is the French
revolu reolution now we're we're going
to spend a lot of time on the French
Revolution next semester so I don't want
to spend too much time on it right now
okay but but you know the basic outline
of the French Revolution right where um
the nobility and the mar were
overthrown and they established a new
ref government and the monarchies of
Europe United against France because
they saw France as a threat to the
established social order of
Europe and
the French revolutionaries were able to
defeat the combined armies of Europe and
under Napoleon they established a French
Empire
okay so all three in incidents are very
similar to what
happened um in the Arabian
peninsula in 600 uh C
so in other
words what I believe happened is the
Muslims
were the world's
first Global
Revolution okay so let me explain what I
mean by
that okay so first of all
let's let's better understand the araban
peninsula
at this time okay so this is the year
600 and again there are two major world
Empires between the araban peninsula
there's the Byzantine Empire which is
basically like like this okay okay this
these are byzantines so and they are
thees to the Romans so basically the
Eastern Roman Empire okay and they still
think think of themselves as the Roman
Empire but historically we we call them
the bantine now and over here
okay are what we call the
sassanian Persian
Empire and as you can see they're huge
okay this is India and this is Spain by
the way okay and this is
Egypt so these are huge World
Empires and then you have the
Arabs in the araban peninsula which is
which is this desert okay
and you look at this map you'll be like
oh my God how was it possible for the
Arabs to defeat both the bantin Empire
and the sassanian Persian Empire and the
answer is this what people don't
understand what do not recognize is in
CE the hotbed of
innovation was actually here in the
araban peninsula this was the most crazy
the most open and the most
Cosmopolitan Center in the world at this
time and and that's what people don't
really understand so let me explain why
okay as you can see from this map Arabia
thean Peninsula is a desert but it's
basically the center of the
world and remember in this class what
you taught is the world has always been
connected through trade
okay so the Arabian Peninsula even
though you can't really have cities
because you don't have any rivers and
you can't really grow crops so you can't
have agriculture they've been trading
with other nations and Civilizations for
thousands of
years okay because there's a crisscross
of Empire so if India wanted to access
Egypt okay because again Egypt for the
longest time was the wealthiest ization
then they had to First send their goods
to Arabia and and then the uh Nomads
would transport the goods into
Egypt
okay so what does it mean to be a
training center well the first thing
that it means is you have access to the
most advanced technology information and
knowledge in the world because you're a
Trader you go everywhere and you bring
back not just Goods but stor stories and
information they know everything about
the world they know exactly what's
happening in the bis Empire they know
exactly what's happening in Assassin
Empire even though most people don't
know what's happening in the desert
okay also because you're
traitors they're extremely open-minded
and
Cosmopolitan they have no prejudices
they have to be friends of
everyone and the third thing is big are
Traders they have to constantly learn
new
information
okay so that's the first unique
characteristic about the Aran Peninsula
at this time these are open-minded
Cosmopolitan people who are constantly
absorbing new information new knowledge
to better their
society the second thing about the
Arabian peninsula is that it's a war
Society you don't have cities you don't
have centralized control just all just
tribes okay just different Clans
different families fighting each other
so honor is very important if you offend
someone in my family we go to war okay
but guess what because they're always at
War these are
strong
brave people who know how to fight and
that's why both the byzantines and the
cians hired these people as
mercenaries okay and so as mercenaries
they were learning the most advanced
Warcraft military doctrine of both the
Assassin and the
byzantines they have these were the best
soldiers in the world
basically and what happened is that over
time the byzantines and assassins would
establish
client
um States within the Arabian Peninsula
okay so these are client
states all right so there so that's the
second thing this is a war Society okay
who know how to
fight the third thing that makes the
Aran Peninsula so Innovative is its
diversity all right so what what what do
I mean by that okay so as we discussed
last class Augustine creates this
intellectual blueprint for the Catholic
church and the focus is on obedience
okay the idea is
Orthodoxy meaning there is only one
proper way to understand our religion if
you if you disagree then it's
heresy okay and as we discussed the
problem with the Christian religion is
it's very very
confusing so we talked about about the
example of the godhead right Jesus Holy
Spirit and God are one and the same well
this creates a lot of problems for
example the very basis of the Christian
religion is that Jesus died for our sins
right Jesus was sacrificed he was
crucified and he suffered for our
sins here's a question though how does
God
suffer how does God die that makes no
sense so one the
that has never ended okay even today
Christians still fight fight over it's
the idea of christology what is the
nature of Christ is he Divine is he
human is he
both is he half half was he human here
and then Divine up there there are lots
of
possibilities and even today Christians
cannot
agree
Okay so F even so from the first day
Christians have fought over each other
um
over the nature of Christ and the nature
of the godhead okay and again because of
or Orthodoxy there's only one
interpretation and you must follow that
interpretation and if you don't follow
that interpretation guess what uh you
either have to go somewhere else or you
die and so they're forced to go East
right they either go to the sassan
Empire or they go to the araban desert
many CH
School Arian desert why because in Aran
desert there's no Cal Authority you're
free to practice the faith as you
choose and guess
what often those who are the most her
heretical those who want to practice
your own faith are the most Innovative
because they like to ask questions they
like to explore they want to practice a
personal faith they believe that God is
someone you communicate with right the
Catholic Church demands that you can
only access God through priests you're
not to read the Bible you're not you're
not allowed to question
Orthodoxy and the most intelligent
people want to do that they want to
speak to God they want to practice own
personal faith they want to ask
questions and in those what and and in
this world at this time the only place
you can do that is the Arabian Desert
you have lots of Christians here
Christians who are um very controversial
they all end up in the Arabian Desert
okay in order to practice their faith
you also have a lot of Jews in the Aran
desert why well first of all I mean the
Aran desert is very close to Jerusalem
right so there there's always been used
there as
traitors and when they go to Iran desert
remember this is common story
about uh how the Arabs and the Jews come
from one big family Abraham okay so
they're able to coales in in a mingle in
Mary fairly easily you also had a lot of
Jews who are
escaping persecution right you also have
a lot of Jews who fought in the Civil
Wars against Rome and they lost and they
had to run to the um uh Arabian Desert
okay so have a lot of Jews here as well
you also have zorin uh from the Assassin
Empire who again want to practice their
own personal faith so the Arabian Desert
it is a
hotbed of religious diversity and
religious
tolerance you are allowed to practice
any th and people respect
that
okay and
again they have some of the smartest
Jews and Christians and Jans in the
world at this point
people who will
eventually lend their expertise to the
Arab military
machine all right so they will help the
Arabs develop Innovative Siege Warfare
and Military Doctrine and science as
well okay does that make
sense at the same time while Arabia is
increasing in terms of innovation and
wealth and
diversity both the buys and
and assassin are declining in terms of
in terms of social uh stability okay so
as we discussed in this class whenever
you have
stability what happens is you will
eventually have inequality and
Corruption so people within the bisan
Empire are extremely unhappy for three
reasons the first reason
is the problem of landlessness
second problem is debt these are
problems that have existed throughout
human
history why are there so many
Revolutions in Chinese history because
of these two two problems right because
there are few people who control all the
land and because the peasants get into
debt so much that they can't they can't
pay it back and their entire family for
Generations are enslaved to the
landlords but also at this time because
of the Catholic Church you also have the
problem of
religious
persecution all right you are not
allowed to practice your own faith you
are only allowed to practice the faith
that the Catholic Church demands of
you and the same situation is also true
in the Persian Empire all right so the
people are extremely
unhappy at the same time there's a lot
of instability within the government of
these Empires why well first of all
because they're always fighting each
other okay so Wars they're always
fighting each other and that causes them
to lose a lot of resources okay second
is whenever you have large cities you
have the problem of plagues right
disease plagues so there are these um
plagues called the
Justin Justinian plague that wiped out
about 10 to 20% of the population at
this point
and the third problem is Civil Wars
right because whenever an emperor dies
they fight over who's the next
Emperor so in other
words we think it seems that the
byzantines and the Sans are really
strong and the Arabs are really weak
when you actually analyze it you realize
that oh wow the bisans are extremely
weak the Assassin are really weak and
the Arabs are really strong the problem
with the Arabs though is they're divided
right they divide into like thousands
tens of thousands of different tribes so
the question now
is how do you unite
them so you need a leader to come and
Inspire the
people okay and this is Muhammad now
what's important for us to understand is
there are lots of different
prophets uh who think they're the
Messiah at this point okay because both
the zor aan religion and the Christian
religion and the um Jewish religion
believe that the Messiah will come okay
and we call
this
apocalyptic eschatology this is very
this is very very
popular right because with Empires
because the more stable Empires are the
more corruption the more inequality the
more social social stagnation there
there are okay so people actually turn
towards the idea of apocalyptic
eschatology
so there are hundred people who who fig
of themselves as a messiah but
eventually Muhammad becomes a messiah of
their people okay and why well
fortunately we have a formulation of a
great leader that we've learned in this
class all right so let me remind you of
this
formulation the first is the person is
so
strategic that he becomes
Visionary second is that the person is
so
Innovative he becomes
revolutionary the third is the person is
so
disciplined he becomes
selfless right and we and so there are
many individuals we've met in this class
that that follow this formula so for
example Phillip of Macedon as well as
Julius
Caesar Phillip and Julius Caesar we we
imagine Warfare
they made their armies into
meritocracies where the very best and
the most loyal were able to rise up in
the ranks regardless of class or cast
okay and they were selfless they were
always in the the first in battle they
put their lives they put the soldiers
lives
first okay and so we can say that
whoever Muhammad was fit would fit this
description okay so let me explain all
right you are in
the Arabian peninsula there are tens of
thousands of different factions
different tribes who have been fighting
each other for centuries they don't
really like each other now how do you
unite them how do you get everyone to
work together and defeat both the Banes
and
assassins well you have if you H if you
have three different
messages you can unite everyone okay the
first message is
this We Are All God's
Children okay Arabs Jews Christians we
are all descendence of Abraham therefore
we are all God's children we are one big
family there should be no religious
difference and persecution Among
Us and because we're all God's children
and because we're all different we
should be free to practice any religion
we want the Christian religion is just
as valid as the Jewish
religion okay so the first thing that
you
say Okay second thing that you will you
can say is
that we are we okay so you're basically
creating meritocracy native meritocracy
is basically Revolution
right the idea of class the idea of cast
the idea of tribal loyalties goes
against the will of God because we're
all God's children we're all equal in
the eyes of God
therefore those who are most willing to
work hard to achieve God's Vision on
Earth should rise to the talk regardless
of your religion regardless of your
class regardless of your cast it's a
meritocracy okay and the third message
is God gave us the promised
land this land that extends from the
Nile to the Tigers is what God promised
us we are all God's children so each and
every one of us should have
land but the bises the Persians stole
this land from
us but the landlords the wealthy stole
it from us therefore we must fight a
Jihad to take it back because that is
God's will when we take it back when we
take it back we'll establish a kingdom
of heaven on
Earth we'll follow God's law God's law
demands
equality it demands mercy and tolerance
it demands
openness that is God's law okay
so it's
Muhammad so in other words Muhammad was
a revolutionary who wanted to overthrow
the social order in order to establish
the Kingdom of Heaven he was the Messiah
promis to the Jews and promised to the
Christians and who will now unite Arabs
Christians and Jews in achieving the
Kingdom of Heaven on Earth that's who
who Muhammad was okay and so
let's go back and we read the
description of Muhammad and his army by
cbles to see if this is correct
okay at that time a certain man from
along the same lines same Sons as if of
Ishmael whose name was mammed a merchant
as if by God's command Okay so he is the
Messiah he's the promised one God has
ordered him to do this appeared them to
as a
preacher okay so he United them
okay and they started to see themselves
as all the children of Abraham and
therefore the children of
God and then mammed gave them the law of
God not to eat carryon not to drink wine
not to speak falsely and not to engage
in fornication this is a law of God this
is the Kingdom of
Heaven he said with an oath God promised
this land to Abraham and his seed after
him forever this is the land that God
promised to us his
children but the Romans have it the
Persians have it the landlords have
it and he brought about as he promised
during that time while he loved Ishmael
but now you are the sons of Abraham and
God is accomplishing his promise of
Abraham and his seed to you okay I have
come to you you as God's Messenger as
God's Prophet to tell you that this land
is yours and you must take it
back love sincerely only the god of
Abraham and go and cease the land which
God gave to your father Abraham cease
the land overthrow the tyrants overthrow
the landlords take it
back no one will be able to resist you
in battle because God is with you okay
so this combines re revolutionary zeal
overturning of social order with
religious devotion God is with us and
this is the same mentality that
drove the French Revolution the war of
the canos in Brazil and the taiping
rebellion
in China and so this is the first truly
Global
Revolution okay and this explains why
the Muslim were able to triumph over
both the byzantines and the Sans because
when they wherever they went they freed
the people
from debt and lessness and religious
persecution you are now allowed to
practice any faith you want you have
that freedom now that's important to
people you now have some land where you
can grow crops and you we will wipe away
your
debt okay
so in less than 100 years okay look look
what
happened they were able to conquer the
entire Persian Empire and
half of the ban
Empire right that's a power
of religious de religious de devotion
and revolutionary
Zeal so that's how they were able to do
it
now the last question we have
is um why don't we know any of this why
isn't this hot in history
books the answer is because the
Revolutionary worked out because they
won they achieved the revolution but now
after they achiev the revolution they
become an
Empire if you're an Empire you don't
want people to revolt against you so you
have to whitewash this history
right you don't want people to know that
Muhammad was a revolutionary so you
changed the
history the history is
that Muhammad was disgusted by the
inequality and Corruption he saw in the
world around
him and he promised the
people freedom from religious
persecution from death and from
landlessness and that's what Drew follow
followers to
him right you don't want another
Muhammad appearing in your
Empire so you change the history and say
that oh no no the real conflict was that
Muhammad wanted
monotheism the Arabs wanted
polytheism that's what the problem
was okay
and the the same is true in China today
right who created the Chinese Revolution
who enabled the Communist Party to
control China Mone
right do you learn about maone in in
school no you don't same thing you
understand so they're trying to
whitewash their history because it's
embarrassing for a global
Empire to celebrate a revolutionary
who hated corruption and inequality
see and that's why there's so little
written about Muhammad and that's why
the Quran doesn't really tell that much
that much that doesn't really tell us
that much about
Muhammad okay because his Revolution
won okay is this clear to you you have
any questions for
okay all right so um we have two more
classes before the semester ends okay
they're both on Dante the reason why is
Dante is the greatest poet the greatest
prophet in human
history and he's really second coming of
Homer remember Homer created Greek
civilization well Dante with his work
the vine comedy will create modern
Europe European civilization okay so
next class next Tuesday we'll start
looking at Dante